[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Good afternoon, everybody.
And thank you for your time.
Thank you, Radcliffe Institute
and the generous donors
of my fellowship for the
wonderful opportunity.
Thank you, Radcliffe,
also for funding
me for the exploratory seminar.
Paul is not here.
Thank you.
It was a cherry on the cake.
Thank you, Liz and Judy,
for your leadership
and stead in this
tremendous program.
Thank you, Sharon and Rebecca.
Thank you, Paul and
Asma, for all the help
you rendered to us.
Thank you, Mervi, Katie, and,
yes, thank you, Margarita.
Thank you, Michael
Fischer, for leading me
to this wonderful place.
Thank you, fellow Fellows,
for your fellowship
and the great presentations
you've made thus far.
I hope I don't return
you disappointed today.
Thank you, Reginald, for all
the sacrifices you have made,
and I'm making it public.
Well, I've been thinking how
best to bring you, though.
My job is significantly easy now
of what Judy has already said,
how to bring this book in such
a short period of time to you.
I'm reminded here of
an [INAUDIBLE] poet who
tells his beloved that, should
you like, I will tell you--
I will justify the title.
Telling the entire tale
would take a lifetime.
Let me then briefly
justify my title.
And I'm reading
this because I'm not
a scholar of art and literature.
Therefore, I find
prose very difficult.
I'm very good at other things.
The book Life in
the Himalaya reveals
Himalaya's past and
present in terms
of its natural and
cultural endowments
vis-a-vis contemporary
challenges it faces.
I hope the book will bring this
important but much neglected
region into sharp
international focus.
Life in the Himalaya
explores the mountain
in its four distinct stages.
One, the natural
phase, which comprises
Himalaya's geobiological
consolidation and development
of human culture that symbolizes
moksha, or the salvation,
salvation through human
expression of mountain temple
metaphor.
It points to an
imminent human impulse
to reconstruct the
mountain and therefore
a yearning for ascension.
The second phase, the cultural
phase, of the Himalaya
covers nomadic pastoral
communities for the last 15,000
years, and it reaches the climax
with commercial deforestation
during British raj, who
sowed the seeds of discontent
and conflict between the
people, the local communities,
and the state.
And then the third phase,
the mechanical phase,
which is marked by burgeoning
human population growth,
urbanization, and large-scale
infrastructure and dam
projects, which are causing
unprecedented ecosystem
degradation and
biological extinctions.
And finally, the need for a
network phase, or networking
phase, which necessitates
information sharing
and institutional
cooperation in search
of the safe space
for the Himalaya.
Now this is the
kind of a context.
And before I get to
my slides, I also
want to read a para from
chapter two of my proposed book.
This is titled "The
Lure Of the Mountain,
Sacrifice and the
Moksha." "The Himalaya
predates the arrival
of humans on Earth,
but celebration of its grandeur
is entrenched in the lore
and legend of the mountain.
The Himalayan memoir
forms an integral part
of the shared
inheritance of Asia,
where humans witnessed the
final phase of Himalaya
rise towards the end of
the Pleistocene glaciation.
The grand spectacle that
unfolded before our ancestors'
eyes must have been an edifying
experience for the mind.
Hindus often speak of such
experience in terms of Ananda,
which presages boundless sense
of fulfillment and peace.
And it means much more
than joy and bliss.
"The massive rock that
stands high above the ground
is not merely a
conglomeration of stone,
but to the worst
humanity, irrespective
of color, creed,
faith, and nationality,
it is a living magnet that pulls
the weak and the strong alike
towards it.
The Himalaya's unequal vocal
exhortation by the visitor
goes beyond a simple description
of the scenic beauty,
the sparkling snowfields,
the flower tapestry
and the fragrance, the diversity
of life and its colors.
The journey alone
elevates the experience
to a deeper understanding
and meaning of life."
The Himalayan legend
abounds in symbols
that underpin man's abiding
faith in the sacredness
and divinity of the mountain.
Willi Unsoeld--" I'm not able
to pronounce it properly.
It's Unsoeld.
He was a Swiss-American,
the first American
to scale Mount
Everest in 1963, was
so enthralled by the divine
pull of Nanda Devi, which
is about 8,000 meters,
that he named his daughter
Nanda Devi after the mountain.
Nanda Devi Unsoeld was
a proficient mountaineer
and accompanied her father
on several such mountain
expeditions.
Sadly, during one
of the expeditions
to trek in Himalaya, young Nanda
Devi died on September 8, 1976,
at age 22.
She had gone against
team physicians' advice
to go down to a lower level
because of the snowstorm.
Nanda Devi was a
wildlife biology major
and had developed great
interest in conservation
of endangered species,
such as cats of the East.
Even though she was averse
to mountain climbing
as a full-time vocation,
she felt almost mystical
about the climb she
was about to undertake.
Before setting off for what
turned out to be her last time,
she told an interviewer,
which I quote here.
"I can't describe it, but
there is something within me
about this mountain
ever since I was born."
Unquote.
Willi Unsoeld buried his
daughter around Camp 4
at 7,300 meters under the
snows of her namesake mountain.
There is no way to verify
if Willi Unsoeld had known
that in Garhwal Himalaya
Nanda is metaphorically
used for daughters.
My wife, when addressed as
Nanda by her grandmother,
caught me by surprise
some years ago.
Now let me now go to my slides.
So this has already been
talked, so I will not.
So let me go to the beginning.
Why Himalaya?
What do we need to
know about Himalaya?
What is so important
about Himalaya?
What we need to appreciate is
that Himalaya, once it emerged,
changed the way
the Earth operated.
So emergence of
Himalaya was, we know,
considered as one of the most
significant geophysical events
in a billion years,
in 100 million years.
So it was remarkable.
And one of the significances
was that Himalaya,
just at the beginning
of Cenozoic,
it started a global
cooling effect.
So Earth completely cooled.
And the reason was that this
massive land surface, which
is just about 4% of the
world's land surface,
it contributes to 85%
of global sediment flux.
So a lot of chemical
weathering of rocks
uses up silicate, which takes
up lots of carbon dioxide,
and then it is
buried under ocean.
Therefore, once there
is huge carbon dioxide
withdrawal from the atmosphere,
then there's global cooling.
Geologically, it is the youngest
and the tallest mountain.
Biologically, it is the longest
bioclimatic elevation gradient.
Hydrologically, this is the
most elaborate drainage network
of 10 basins.
And it's a global
biodiversity hot spot
with most biodiverse biomes,
even more diverse than others.
The least known
scientifically, unfortunately.
There is high species and
human culture diversity.
One thing which I
want to pause here.
I was surprised while I was
researching for this book
that the entirety within
plateau, which is thousands
of squares of kilometers, has
just about five or six dialects
spoken in this entire
from west to east.
But if you come down to the
southern declivity of Himalaya,
there are 800-plus
dialects spoken.
In fact, there is a joke
in Arunachal Pradesh,
if you cross the
river, you'll not
be able to understand
the other guy
on the other side of the bank.
So so much of diversity.
And so 10 major diverse systems.
These also report as third pole
because it has the largest ice
fields outside of the
polar regions, 1,600
square kilometers.
Then 1 and 1/2 million
people live in its basins.
And we believe that it is
the warmest mountain, warmest
of the mountains on Earth.
And [INAUDIBLE] my home.
And thirdly, it is also the
most militarized mountain
in the world.
So the oldest
description of Himalaya
goes back to
Kumara-Sambhavan of Kalidasa.
And I have absolutely no idea.
2,500 years ago, how did
this guy, who was a poet,
he says that this is the
only mountain on Earth
which sings to the eastern
and the western seas.
And this is, of course-- then he
writes of all the great poetry.
But this was in
fifth century BC.
And when the first of
these satellite images
came and then people
realized, indeed, this
is the only mountain
which exactly--
if you go to the east,
then through Uttarakhand,
you must then go down almost
touching the Pacific Ocean.
And on the western
side through Hindu Kush
and the Suleiman ranges to
the Caucasus almost touch,
they do touch the western sea.
I have no idea that how did he
do it, what kind of mechanism
he had to know it.
So possibly I think poets
have that strange vision which
scientists lack.
Ross, that makes you happy.
Now going to the
birth of Himalaya,
I call it tectonic
serendipity because, as you
can see, about 225
million years ago
India was part of
this Gondwanaland.
And this is the only Southern
Hemisphere craton or plate
which started a
northward journey.
And it made a journey of
4,000 miles at varying speeds,
from 4 and 1/2 centimeters,
4 and 1/2 centimeters
to 18 centimeters.
And then docked itself here
just below the Eurasian Plate.
And once it docked-- this
is the Eurasian Plate
and this is the
approaching Indian Plate.
In between is the Tethys Sea.
So slowly, when the Indian Plate
approached the Eurasian Plate,
got docked under
it because it was
a denser plate, got submerged.
And tectonic forces, then
this is how it got lifted,
and that's how
Himalaya were born.
I'm simplifying it.
Therefore, people suggested that
it was a continental collision.
So sometimes
collisions are good.
It's not bad.
It's not such a bad idea.
So therefore, once
these tectonic processes
were completed, they led
to landform evolution,
but at the same
time there became
this huge wall,
this mountain wall,
became barrier to
moist winds, which were
coming from the Indian Ocean.
Therefore, for the
first time-- one
of the most beautiful seasons
in India is called monsoon.
There's nothing on this
world like monsoon.
So first time
Indian subcontinent
experienced the
rainfalls of the monsoon
about 20 million to 10 million
years ago, there is a lot of,
you know.
And once the elevational
gradient became high,
you had these glaciers.
So you have monsoons,
you have glaciers.
And then once you have glaciers,
there are perennial rivers.
And once this stage is
set, the humans arrive.
This is such remarkable--
and I will come to it--
I am not for a moment suggesting
that there is some design,
intelligent design.
But what was
happening that nothing
was happening till Miocene?
What was happening, of course,
is that Himalaya, once it got
docked under the
Asian Plate, it became
a sort of international
biological highway.
So by that time
it was still warm,
so you had large number of
species coming as far as North
America, going through, and
then crossing this Indochinese
plateau, and going up
to Japan and vice versa.
So a kind of an
international exchange
happened because of Himalaya.
That's part one.
Part two is that recent
genetic studies now
confirm that the evolution and
being the Indian subcontinent
played an extremely
important role to the march
of human civilization.
But for it, human
civilization wouldn't
have progressed beyond it.
This is a paper in Science
where they would clearly say,
I wanted to see that what
if India wasn't there?
How can we-- so I,
of course-- so this
is how it looks without India.
So India is not here.
So India still is not here.
And now humans cannot cross
this Arabian Peninsula,
go north because it is Ice Age.
Ice Age, which
lasted throughout.
So there was no way.
So what happened was
therefore, so we bring India
back here, OK?
So by magic India comes in.
So once India comes here,
it forms a complete terrain,
terrestrial connectivity between
oceans which are separated.
And then they proliferate
all over the world.
I'm not again suggesting that,
if Indian Plate was not there
or Himalaya were not
there, human civilization
couldn't have progressed.
But surely it
would have got, you
know, delayed by
25,000 years minimum.
OK?
So you can imagine where
it would have been now.
I will go through this
quickly because this
is how a simple mountain
chain can be transformed
into complex physiography.
I do not want, again, go
into geophysical details
but simply to tell you that--
imagine a mountain slope.
OK?
So small pressure from below,
which is the tectonic force.
And the river and
glaciers, they act as saws.
And so this is
how it looks like.
So a river cuts a
V-shaped valley,
and a glacier makes what is
called a U-shaped valley.
So Himalaya is only
about V-shaped valleys
and U-shaped valleys.
So from a simple structure it
became a complex topography.
So you have at the end of, as
I said, at the end of Miocene
and Pleistocene, so you have
all kinds of species coming
from North America, China,
Europe, Mediterranean,
all places.
And then agriculture
started about 4,000,
5,000, 6,000 years ago.
So this is the kind of
profile that Himalaya
came to have in the
eastern and western side.
There's a little
bit of difference
between east and west
because, as you can see here,
the western side is 34
degrees north latitude.
This is 24 degrees.
So there's a 10-degree
difference between latitude.
Therefore, there is a
little bit of difference
between eastern and
western Himalaya.
But general profile, this is how
the general profile of Himalaya
looks like.
So coming to part two.
I know I have to cover a lot of
ground, so I'm doing it fast.
So these are some
of the drivers.
Of course, there are global,
there are regional, and local.
I will mostly
concentrate on some
of the local and
regional drivers.
So the first one is this
burgeoning human population
that Judy talked about.
So you have, in the Himalaya,
in the Himalayan region
across the countries, India,
Pakistan, China, or Tibet
or some.
So 2.8 times to four
times there is an increase
in the last 50 years.
So much population
growth in that region,
which has a low carrying
capacity, expanding
agriculture, and
expanding settlements.
Whether these are
mountain tops or valleys,
they are full of people.
Therefore, that is
putting a lot of pressure.
Now you make houses fine.
But you look at
traditional houses.
This was a paper which I
published some years ago.
This is a traditional
kind of a village.
So you have mostly traditional
stone masonry and wood
structures.
The houses are much
broader than tall.
Therefore they can withstand
earthquakes and things
like that.
But you have today these
shanties coming up, which
are mostly reinforced cement
concrete structures, which
add to what is called the
urban heat island effect.
And yeah, so other major
problem with the Himalaya
was that in about 2003,
first set of India reports,
forests of India
reports came, and they
started claiming that Himalayan
forests were increasing indeed.
And if you can see
the Garmin data,
this is how the Garmin data is.
So it's increasing.
So as a regular
visitor to Himalaya,
I found this rather
disconcerting that agriculture
is expanding, human
settlements are expanding,
all kind of infrastructure
is expanding.
Unless Earth is elastic, you
can't have forests expanding.
So there must be
something wrong with it.
So I started this work.
This was almost
literally back-breaking.
So you had almost 370
such pieces to exactly one
by one from east to west to do.
And we did this.
And what we found
was that there was
massive deforestation in the
Himalaya, across the Himalaya.
And you can see, this is a
closeup picture you can see.
In 1970, these
were dense forests.
And you can see here.
So camera doesn't lie.
So most of these
dense forests were
converted into open forests,
so deforestation was going on.
The second unfortunate problem
we found is that, as I said,
it's in a highly
militarized zone.
I have no time to go
to the politics of it.
But simply to tell you that
no ecology, no ecologists,
no biologists, nobody
has even looked
at the impact of
roughly 10 million to 13
million individuals living
there in that mountain space.
What kind of impact it's
having, nobody knows.
But I'll just start.
What impact it had
was that you must
be aware of China-Tibet
engagement in 1950s.
So one thing which
China did to begin with
was to have a massive
road network built
in the entire region.
And which culminated
recently in what
I-- this is a chapter in my book
called "First Train to Lhasa."
And therefore, this
was essentially
to sustain the military's
kind of infrastructure
which was there.
And India wanted road for road.
So because there
was a massive defeat
which India suffered in 1962
war at the hands of China.
So there was a lot of pressure
on the Indian government
that we should have a
large number of roads.
Be that as it may, so
roads infrastructure
started coming up.
There's another chapter,
which I call "Streetcar."
At that point of
time in 1970s, we
had Mrs. Gandhi as
the prime minister.
Her son was another very,
very nice gentleman.
So he wanted to
revolutionize motor vehicle
industry in India.
So he started a company called
Maruti at that point of time.
Unfortunately, he did
not live to see that.
He died in an air crash.
But subsequently Maruti did.
And Maruti changed the
complete landscape of Himalaya.
Now this again,
nobody talks about it.
You can see till about 1980,
you have about 25,000 cars
being manufactured in India.
And suddenly after '80 you
can see this boom going up.
And then what it had--
once you have roads,
once you have a nice little car
which can take four, five, six
people to close-by mountain,
then most of the people
living in the towns and
cities near Himalaya,
so everybody on a weekend
would just put father,
mother, maybe two children,
just go, and go to Himalaya.
And what it-- and
of course, as Judy
said, that this neoreligious
awakening in Himalaya.
Pardon me by saying
so, but if Muslims
can go to hajj, why can't
we go to our destination?
So a massive movement of
people across the Himalaya.
Fortunately, unfortunately,
most of our gods,
they chose Himalaya.
We are pursuing them even there.
We are not leaving them alone.
OK.
So the consequence
in scientific terms
was that now you had a lot of
vehicles going into the region.
And this carbon black
and other pollutants
are increasing heavy.
Now look here.
You can see this is
Satopanth Glacier.
Satopanth Glacier
is the glacier which
is very close to where from
Ganga or Ganges comes out.
Now you have roughly
3.6 or 116 times higher
than Arctic and Antarctic
the black carbon levels.
You can imagine in those
deep, high valleys of Himalaya
you have such huge
amounts of carbon black.
And the consequence is that
the glaciers are now melting
because of carbon black.
It absorbs the
light much faster,
and therefore the
glacier recession
has started in a big, big way.
So the fourth problem is what
I call in a chapter called
"Dam Rivers Damn Rivers."
So in that these are
a couple of works
which we published where
we find that Himalaya
is likely to have the highest
dam densities in the world.
That means that for every
kilometer or every 14
kilometers, there's
going to be a dam.
Every 14 kilometers in length.
And other places it is anywhere
between 57 to 70 kilometers.
Once upon a time graph
talked about America
being a dam nation.
But India and China are soon
going to replace America
as a dam nation, dam nations.
So we have today, we have today
nearly 1,300 dams on two sides
of the Himalaya coming out.
So about 550 dams in India,
Pakistan, Nepal, and Bhutan
and then roughly about
750 across Tibet.
So we're looking at
something called 1,300 dams.
You can imagine if somebody
after five or six years or 10
years took a satellite
picture, so Himalaya would look
like a moth-eaten Himalaya.
Only small ponds and rivers
flowing through turbines
or [INAUDIBLE] inside.
There's no water.
You'll never see now those
waters coming through.
So that's one.
We were also interested
that, after all,
where were these dams located.
What kind of conflict they had
with the biological diversity
of Himalaya.
And this is an
unrelated work which
we were doing at that time.
This was purely
an academic work,
that how species are
distributed across the Himalaya,
does it mean that all
species occur everywhere.
But what we found was that
across the taxonomic groups,
whether they are mammals and
fish or birds, butterflies,
and plants.
So you have these mid-altitudes
or mid-elevations where you
have maximum number of species.
And when we superimposed hydro
projects or dams on them,
we found there was
a perfect overlap.
I'm sure that nobody had
designed it that way,
but it turned out to be this
was an unfortunate overlap.
And therefore what
we-- so this is how,
these are pictures of the dams.
Then we got to look
at, OK, all right, this
is happening to
terrestrial ecosystems.
What's happening to
the rivers themselves?
So what we found was
in summary that, if you
have more water in a river
at a given point of time,
you are likely to have
more number of species
in that river, fish species.
If you decrease the quantum
of water yield in the river,
then the species
richness in that river
will significantly go down.
That's part one.
Part two is this was a recent
work which we published
about two months back that
some of the endemic species
are almost getting--
they are going
extinct from large
number of Himalayan
rivers because of dams
and also water withdrawal.
So whether it is
terrestrial ecosystems
or aquatic ecosystems
like rivers,
that is a problem everywhere.
We did this study which we
use species [? relative to ?]
the models and predicted that
by the turn of the century
there would be just 10% of dense
forest left in the Himalaya
and nearly 25% of the endemic
species which are only
found in the Himalaya
would go extinct.
Now part third of my talk is the
lead motive of my being here.
So by 2001, 2002, 2003, there
was a lot of talk going on.
There's a new term.
And that started developing
these-- they called themselves
climate change skeptics.
And they started saying
that, oh, it's all hogwash,
there's no truth in it,
there's nothing [INAUDIBLE].
And when the endorsement
came from the top, then
it makes it all
the more serious.
So at that point of time,
we were investigating this.
And we were surprised
to find these plants.
I have to say 120, 130
years, or 100 years.
So it wasn't that surprising.
But what was surprising was
that they were not located
where they were known earlier.
They were located at
much higher elevations.
At that point of time we
cautiously suggested that
possibly, because they were
finding cooler temperatures
higher, about 500 to 800
meters, so they had migrated.
But we didn't have any proof.
So naturally a
professor can do nothing
more than look for a graduate
student that was a zealot.
So a zealot joined, and
she said, I will do it.
So we got together.
We were lucky, actually.
We were looking for
a historical data
set that, can we go back
possibly 150 or 130 years
and then revisit
those areas and then
see, then see comparatively
that, was there any change
happening?
We were, as I
said, we got lucky.
We had two data sets, one
of Smith and Cave, 1911,
and then also 1872 of Hooker's.
We looked at 124 endemic
species, 121 sampling
locations, and 625 study plots.
These are the kind of areas
which we visited and studied.
Yeah, so OK.
So these are the kind of species
that we were looking for.
These are only endemics.
We took only endemics because
if we had projected species
elevation range shifts, then
people could have criticized us
that you know this
species grows there,
there, there, everywhere.
So we took only endemic species,
grown only in those areas.
These are-- OK, I'll
will not go here.
So, and what we find indeed
is that exactly there
was a climate-induced elevation
range that a large number, most
of these species, almost
90% of the species,
had moved almost
800 to 1,000 meters.
And then we also were lucky
that we had historic temperature
data sets of the seasons.
What we found,
interestingly, was
that those summers
were relatively warmer,
but it was winters that
were more warm than usual.
So that was one key finding.
And what we also found was that
the lapse rate-- the lapse rate
means that every 100
meters you go up,
how much temperature in degrees.
So the historic
lapse rate, which
was 1872 which
Hooker had recorded,
was 0.82 degrees
Celsius per 100 meters.
What we found was 0.42.
So almost half.
So lapse rate.
And then, as I said, more winter
warming than what was recorded.
So what we found
was that now suppose
a species has this kind of
a range prior to warming,
now it had like this.
So the range, elevation
ranges, had shortened,
and they had been pushed up.
Now the problem was
that we also found
that species richness per
hectare had decreased.
This problem was because
those species which
had area available to them
to colonize, they could go,
but there's a limit to space.
So those which did not
have, they went extinct.
So a large number of species
went extinct in the Himalaya.
So now the last part of the
talk is the payback time.
Look at this.
This is what's happening.
This is the Mutri Glacier
from where Ganges comes out.
This is the 1780 level,
and this is 2001 level.
And these are glaciers
across the Himalaya.
You can see all glaciers
across the Himalaya
are showing recession
and decrease.
This is an interesting
photograph of 1921 and 2009.
You can see again
glaciers disappearing
and now glacier lakes coming.
In our own studies we
found that, for example,
in [INAUDIBLE] Himalaya
we found that not only had
the number of glacier lakes
increased in the last 30 years,
but the volume of glacier
lakes, the volume of water
had also increased.
Now does Himalayan change
mean a global problem?
I think yes.
Now what does this mean?
Now look at this.
These are some of
the recent-- well,
the data is old but
the emphasis is new.
You have a lot of whatever
increase in sea level
will happen it will happen
because of melting of ice.
And these studies show that,
for every 100-meter rise,
35 centimeters will be
contributed by the recession
of Himalayan glaciers.
Therefore, about 40 million
years back, Himalaya
played a key role in bringing
temperatures of entire Earth
down by several degrees.
Now it is possible that
the Himalayan glaciers
will raise sea levels
significantly globally.
Therefore it must concern
coastal Americans as much.
Now the cumulative
impacts of all this,
again, using species richness,
species/area relationship
models, we found what
will happen in each case.
And this is a
depressing scenario,
that a large number of
species will go extinct.
But more importantly, what
is happening in the Himalaya
is that these lovely alpine
meadows are disappearing.
They're disappearing fast.
You can see this is, again,
a kind of a modeling study
which we projected
in 2050, 2070 using
these representative
conservation
pathways of carbon dioxide.
You can see the shrubs
are increasing in extent
and herbs are slowly
decreasing in extent.
This is how it looks,
the scenario, by 2070.
You'll have very few herbaceous
communities and mostly
the shrub communities.
This is how the
Valley of Flowers
looked in 1970s and late 1970s.
This is how it looks today.
So you can see, a large number
of shrubs and woody plants
getting into these alpine.
Now what it means is that
this kind of disappearance
of alpine meadows
in the Himalaya
is sharply bringing in
conflict the people who
are dependent on
these first resources.
So most of their
traditional medicine
comes from these
herbaceous plants.
And most of their
spices, condiments,
which they use in
their daily lives,
they still come from there.
I have taken one
example of yak here.
Yak is at the base
of the pyramid.
Now there's nothing
yak cannot do.
In fact, the Himalayan highlands
were colonized by humans
only after they
could domesticate
or partially domesticate yak.
Because yak gave,
whether it is dung,
whether it is cheese,
whether it is meat.
And at times when it
becomes extremely--
when there's no water,
it gives them the blood.
They drink its blood.
So even after death, the bones
are made into these nice pipes.
You can see.
And the fat is used for lighting
lamps, whether in monasteries
or in houses.
Or this nice wool.
Or the under fur and the long
fur is used in making tents.
Or sometimes if you wish,
you can have a nice wig.
And then the combs to
take care of that wig.
So therefore, this
particular animal
is central to that culture,
is central to that habitat
and ecosystem.
If the grasses are gone.
Because yak does not
know, yak doesn't
know how to eat shrubs,
rhododendron and select shrubs,
it just doesn't know.
It only knows eating grass.
And if grass goes,
then yak goes.
If yak goes, a whole lot
of cultural extinction
will happen, which would
be a sad tragedy on Earth.
Therefore, some years
back, again, I've
been getting lucky
several times in my life.
So when the editors
of Nature accepted
that I should bring
this to the world focus,
I wrote an op-ed in Nature.
And that's how I brought
this world focus,
and that's how Michael
Fischer got in touch with me
and that's how I came to
The Radcliffe Institute.
Finally, I just want
to end this talk
by quoting Emily Dickinson
and daughter of New England.
This is called "God
Made a Little Gentian."
You must have been
sort of surmising,
why am I talking about gentian?
What has gentian
got to do with it?
This is what it has got.
It says, "God made
a little gentian.
It tried to be a
rose and failed,
and all the summer laughed.
But just before the snows,
there came a purple creature
that ravished all the hill.
And summer hid her forehead
and mockery was still.
The frosts were her condition.
The Tyrian would not come."
Tyrian is this color.
We have been talking
about this color.
"The Tyrian would not come
until the North evoked it.
'Creator, shall I bloom?'"
So the problem is we can
keep on fighting whether it
is one degree Celsius, two
degrees Celsius, or half
a degree Celsius.
We can keep on discussing it
between climate doomsday sayers
and skeptics and what you have.
The problem is, does
North evoke the frost?
If North is unable
to evoke frost,
we will not have gentians,
we will not have grasses,
we will not have yak.
If we do not have that, then
our own survival is in danger.
Thank you for your
patient listening.
[APPLAUSE AND MUSIC PLAYING]